but also if you really think about the
fact that we are in a world where people
have to go to work to do a job that by
the way man if there is a dude you need
to get on this podcast and there's a
book that you would love David Graeber
wrote this book called [ __ ] jobs
this guy is a [ __ ] genius man in this
book [ __ ] jobs breaks down the
phenomena of how many many people are
working in jobs that don't do anything
for the world or the company they're
working for and it's not like this
judgemental thing where he's like yeah
that's a [ __ ] job you're a bla bla
bla he's one of the he's like a
anthropologist so he's very precise but
one of the qualifications for your job
to be a [ __ ] job is you know that
it's really kind of a worthless job it's
not really doing anything and like the
companies have gotten so [ __ ] big
that they they end up having like
departments or people running
departments or extra employees that
don't really need to be there at all and
they have to pretend to be to work
that's what he writes about he writes it
the if you really want to torture a
person not only give them like the job
of like you know pouring a glass of
water and an empty glass and pouring it
back but then add to it that they have
to deceive their boss into thinking that
they're like doing an important job or
they lose their job so these not only
are these like some corporations and
companies scanning your piss to see if
you're taking a substance that is
allowing you to connect with home what
you actually are they are also demanding
that you spend many hours a day lying to
them that you're doing work that you're
not doing if you're [ __ ] efficient
you know and this is another thing
Graber writes about forgive me David
Graeber fan anyway I'd misconstrue this
I read your writings stoned but but the
the the the other [ __ ] element to
that is absolutely atrocious and [ __ ]
horrible is that these substances are
connecting us to home they don't want us
to be in those states and they're asking
us to [ __ ] lie all day and you know
what psychedelic means the the etymology
of psychedelic no it means mind
manifesting or soul manifesting right so
a psychedelic connects us potentially
with the truth what we are our identity
right and these companies they're asking
us to lie to be the opposite of our debt
identities to wear weird a suitors are
some kind of dress code and to sit in a
desk where because you're efficient you
get your job done in 45 minutes and for
the next six hours you got to sit and
type and pretend that you're working
knowing you're a person and knowing that
this is like unethical you're but if you
if you like go and tell your boss hey
man I don't really have much to do you
might get fired the boss might like in
the book he cites one person cuz he did
like a survey and he cites one person
who went to her boss and she's like hey
I can finish my job in two hours
I need can I have other stuff to do and
her boss is like don't talk about that
stay quiet about that oh yeah man that's
the [ __ ] world were in right now
because of automation there's less to do
computers are making [ __ ] fat that's why
are we work we're working the exact same
amount of time we were when there were
no computers but you have to be there to
get paid and you have to act like you're
doing something or they can you yeah so
many people right now are doing just
that
while they're listening to this a lot a
lot and by the way you've you had a
guess what percentage of people are
listening right now that are really
supposed to be doing some [ __ ] job
and they're kind of sitting in front of
their keyboard with earbuds on just
barely paying attention try not to get
caught looking a port yeah I probably
and all over the planet over a million
over a million in the workforce probably
when do you think companies had
to put in rules that you can't look at
porn at work like that wasn't a thing in
the 70s who wasn't a thing in the 80s
right it wasn't a thing in the nine
right then all of a sudden you could
just find porn online and people will
they have a work computer that's hooked
up to the internet like when did
companies start going oh yeah we didn't
know about that yeah you can't look at
that dude I mean I'm sure it started
with like penthouse right like you and
when they have penthouse like Penthouse
magazine like you know for sure you
could bring I couldn't bring your
penthouse your [ __ ] hustler to work
that's true but the but looking at
something online is so much easier than
going to the store and getting a hustler
like the access is universal
you're instantaneous everyone has the
the ability to just go and download it
you know if we're gonna like ask
questions that are impossible to answer
it's like how many people right now do
you think listening to the podcast are
in their [ __ ] job jerking off the
porn while they listen at least one dude
yeah sure that's what dudes do yeah I
mean kids they can get away with it they
jerk off especially a guy with a bad job
who could find a way to jerk off
somewhere yes just keep five minutes in
this bathroom with jerk-off just sorry I
think about the stupid [ __ ] job dude
come on like that's like sexual assault
I don't think you're taking off in an
office none that what if you scream if
everyone knows you're gonna go hey I'm
gonna go in there I'm gonna turn it off
when I come I scream
that's sexual assault oh well that is I
[ __ ] feel like suing you right now
man